today we're talking about the updated
gta trilogy getting a trailer advanced
wars one plus two getting delayed and
more my name is davonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
so waking up and finally getting to see
the definitive edition of the gta
trilogy is one thing but then realizing
that it's less than a month away from
release is a totally separate thing and
i am shooketh following weeks of rumors
and then an official announcement from
rockstar grant that photo the trilogy
the definitive edition now has a shiny
new trailer to show off its updated
visuals digital versions of the three
game package will be released on
november 11th on ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox
series x and s nintendo switch and pc
through the rockstar games launcher
additionally rockstar confirmed a
standalone version of gta san andreas
the definitive edition is coming to game
pass on november 11th while gta 3 the
definitive edition will be available on
playstation now beginning december 7.
december 7th is also the day that
physical additions for xbox series xns
xbox one nintendo switch and ps4 will be
released however rockstar made no
mention of a physical version for
playstation 5. aside from the games
looking better players can also look
forward to a gta 5 style controller
layout improved gunplay and targeting
controls updated mini maps with enhanced
navigation
the ability to immediately restart a
failed mission and more switch players
can expect gyro aiming and the use of
the touchscreen for camera zooming pans
and menu selections i'm all for enhanced
visuals but honestly they could have
kept it looking the way it did and just
gave me the better controls and i would
have paid 70 bucks just for that let me
know what you thought of the trailer and
and the way it looks it's a little
cartoony i've seen some people on
twitter not really feeling it it's a
little mixed bag but i'm loving it i
can't wait so let me know
and now let's talk about a game that
isn't coming out this year nintendo has
announced that advance wars oneplus 2
reboot camp has been delayed until
spring 2022. the game was originally
scheduled to launch later this year on
december 3rd for nintendo switch but
following the delay it no longer has a
specific release date announcing the
news on twitter nintendo stated quote
the game just needs a little more time
for fine tuning you'll be battling with
andy and friends soon thanks for your
patience
and speaking of games with no solid
release date stardew valley creator eric
concerned ape baron has announced his
next game titled haunted chocolatier in
the game players become the next
chocolatier to take over a local
chocolate factory and store which are
located inside a haunted castle baron
put up a blog post on the haunted
chocolatier website detailing the new
game and said in part quote chocolate
represents that which is delightful the
haunted castle represents the allure of
the unknown the ghosts represent the
imprint of the past all these things are
important
and if that announcement wasn't enough
for you then don't worry there's going
to be a new state of play next week on
october 27th at 2 p.m pacific time 5 pm
eastern this event will be focused on
announcements and updates for
third-party games on ps4 and ps5 the
event will be around 20 minutes and will
show off new looks at previously
announced games and some reveals from
playstation studio partners so what do
you want to see from this state of play
personally i really want to know what's
going on with little devil inside it's
been over a year since we've got any
type of update and like
come on even if it's coming out in like
2023 i just want to know
but okay let's switch gears a little to
a console update the xbox october update
has begin to roll out bringing the 4k
dashboard to all xbox series x consoles
announced on the xbox wire this update
also includes night mode settings for
xbox series x and s and the ability to
quickly change the accessibility options
from the xbox guide
and there you have it so let me know
what you're getting into this weekend
what you're playing etc and go follow me
on twitter at devonta chisholm peace
you